今何時だ
今、朝の４時３９分です
こんばんははじめしゃちょーです
ﾌｩﾌ
いつもポケモンGOの動画をサブチャンネルに出すんですけども
テンションが上がった時だけメインにも出します
はじめしゃちょーです
みなさぁん！
まだポケモンGOやってますか
ｽﾞｳ
花粉がやべぇ
花粉がヤバイ中知ってる人は知ってますよね
今ポケモンGOで
ミュウが！出現しています。
でね今までいた伝説のポケモン
とかっていうのはそのレイドバトル
ていって例えばルギア
とかで強い敵を
こうみんなでよってたかってﾎﾞｺﾎﾞｺにするっていうのが
レイドバトルだったんですけどぉ
ミュウはちょっと違いまして
今までのポケモンGO
になかったシステムで手に入る
になってたんですよ
あのこのポケモン待ってごめん鼻が
ポケモンGOに新しいシステムみたいなのが導入されちまって
まぁそれでどんなのかって言いますと
なんかこの博士がいるんすよこのおじさん
うわぁ…
ミュウをうまく誘い出すことができれば
大切なのは真っすぐな心とミュウに会いたいという気持ちを強く持つこと
これ結構後半なんですけど僕この博士から
もう無理難題
おらぁやれやれつって
それを全部クリアした者だけが
ミュウに会える権利がもらえるというシステムでございます
２日間
ぶぉくは２日間
いや３日かなぁ
たぶん３日間だぁ
３日間くらい
全力で
あぁすることありましたよ
いろいろすることとかしなきゃいけないこととかね
お仕事とかいろいろこなしてる中
頑張って時間を見つけて
ﾃﾞｪ!
ﾐｭｳに会う直前まできましたあぁ
マジできつかったっす
もう ﾐｭｳとﾐｭｳ2捕まえたら
初期のポケモン全部捕まえたことになるんですよ
そんなの僕待ってらんないからﾈｪ!
なんとしてでも捕まえたいという一心で
僕はもう
ミュウのミッションをいち早くクリアするしかないと思って
捕まえる寸前までやってきました！
ジョウトはあと2匹です
あと、ドーブルとセレビィで終わりでございます
あざっす！
でちょっとホウエン地方ですね
あの、キモリとかねアチャモとかの世代はまだやり切れてなくて
110匹ぐらいしかまだいないんですけどぉ
なんせ！
なんせもうミュウは目の前まで来たんです
僕3日間全て投げ出して
ほんとにもうこのハカセが言ってくるミッションが
(ﾌﾟﾙﾌﾟﾙﾌﾟﾙﾌﾟﾙﾌﾟﾙ)
ｯﾊｧ⁉⁉
みたいのばっかりでめっちゃ大変でした
どんなのあったっけなぁ
とりあえずなんか
レイドバトル2回やれとか言われて
レイドバトルﾔ...レイドバトルってねその
日中しかやってないんですよ
夜中とかやってないから